première visite guidée de la médiathèque
du canal ce bâtiment construit sur cinq
étages maintenant 1993 la médiathèque du
canal ouvrait ses portes à montigny le
bretonneux 23 ans plus tard elle
s'apprête à montrer son nouveau visage
après un an et demi de travaux les 130
mille ouvrages ont réintégré ses rayons
la capacité d'accueil de la médiathèque
est plus petit puisque un étage un
espace au rez de chaussée
est dédié
au musée l'expérience de la médiathèque
du petit canal
nous a montré qu' il y avait un intérêt
à accueillir des publics de différents
âges dans
dans les espaces on a voulu également
des espaces
assez mixte dans dans le fait ou on
vient pour emprunter mais également ses
journées sur place soit pour travailler
soit pour se détendre grande évasion
bouillon de culture la répartition est
envisagée de manière thématique
les plus petits ont leur propre espace
des espaces réaménagés et un
accompagnement du public par les 33
employés de la structure
on a fait un document mode d'emploi de
la médiathèque pour donner à lire un peu
le bâtiment donc un plan et puis ce
qu'on peut trouver dans chacun des
étages
voilà pour avoir déjà un premier repère
donc ça c'est forcément un document
qu'on va distribuer et puis aura
également des collègues au moins jusqu'à
fin décembre qui vont être là en plus
des postes traditionnels des services
publics pour justement accompagner les
gens allaient au devant de répondre à
leurs questions à la vraiment les
accompagner dans le nouveau bâtiment en
fait la médiathèque du canal accueille
près de 17000 personnes chaque mois ses
portes se rouvriront le mercredi 16
novembre